do you remember the time that you
accidentally deleted the video while we
were out drinking oh my god
do you want to do something even worse
so um
because what happened was we were at a
friend's house yeah and they they were
chromecasting all my [ __ ] videos to
the chromecast
and i don't want to watch my videos this
is about 2 2 a.m in the night so we were
pretty drunk at this point
and um so [ __ ] bad so it was my most
recent video and had a sponsor on it
yeah
right and so here's what here's what
here's what happens right when you have
the youtube app and someone's
chromecasting and you're also connected
you can like uh like move the video like
skip it whatever
and it said like oh like i could click
on the playlist of the cued videos
and it said uh i clicked it and my video
was on i was like i want to turn this
off so
i click it and there was no off button
there was any delete video and i was
like well delete video from the
the chromecast
so i deleted the video on the spot bear
in mind i haven't been paid for the
sponsor yet
and it got paid like and i just uploaded
it like two days ago yeah yeah
and then i i was i realized like 10
minutes late i'm like i'm looking on my
channel like
where's the video going wait
wait did i delete the video and then i
was just sitting there for like all
night sobering up just thinking like i
deleted the [ __ ] video what am i
gonna do
maybe they won't notice that deleted the
video and then
on the on the taxi back which was gone i
was like gone i think i [ __ ] up
what do i do i deleted the sponsor video
i don't know how how do i
how do i play the results recently no no
no no no no no no no no this is this is
the last this is this is back in england
oh okay
yeah it's like yeah yeah i remember
conan connor telling me it's like
yeah i think i deleted a video i'm like
oh i mean so
that's not that bad i just re-upload it
and he's like no i mean
it's a sponsored video and i haven't
been paid for it yet and do you think
the sponsors will notice
i'm just like okay
that's that's a pickle that you're in a
bit of a pickle
and then like they i can't remember who
which sponsor it was i'm pretty sure
they probably shouldn't tell anybody
because they don't want to yeah
uh they emailed me like two days after
they were like hey uh
where's the video coming uh where's it
gone and luckily
i've just been dealing with a channel
like copyright issues yeah yeah and so i
emailed them back and being like oh
gosh darn it that youtube copyright
doing its magic again they've blocked
the video worldwide as i'm like retyping
all the things
i'm like i'm pretty sure i can fix it by
tomorrow at eight a.m
yeah and so i uploaded it and they're
like great work connor back up and i'm
like
thank you man i'm so glad i fixed it i
was like oh my god
so yeah i was really drunk i wasn't i
wasn't even that drunk i wasn't even
telling you i was just like like
really dumb i was just really [ __ ]
dumb i just did it and i was like [ __ ]
that's a bad thing can you please play
me
oh my god i got paid for it in the end
though that's good that's a youtuber's
worst nightmare though
yeah deleting a video not so bad but
having to explain to someone like
why are you delighted yeah i think it's
it's like you know when you have to
explain to your parents that you [ __ ]
up in some
kind of yeah yeah and you're like man i
really i really have to hype myself up
to uh just explain to mum and dad
why this thing has happened oh my god
that's terrible